neglecting your wife. If you neglect
your wife and you give her not a lot of
attention and the way she beautifies
herself for you, the way she cooks for
you, the way she respects you, then
she's going to grow elsewhere.
Yeah. Um I've noticed that anytime a
woman is caught, it's your fault. It's
because of you.
Rather than confiding in you as a
husband, she confides in her male
colleague and says, "Look, I'm going
through this. I'm going through that."
And then he says, "Oh, it's okay. I'm
I'm going to be here for you." that that
specifically that the the the cheating
process starts when she disconnects
herself from her husband. So there has
to be an element of disconnect first.
It's not all the time this problem that
the man is not uh taking all the boxes.
Now sometimes he does take all the boxes
but they still will find a problem to
kind of do certain things to make
excuses for the actions.
I called my wife up. I said listen I've
just finished with work. I may or may
not be taking you up but get your stuff
ready anyway.
I hadn't even that's so inconsistent
to know exactly. I feel like I feel like
they usually will seek out a man who is
very kind and gentle and considerate and
over like giving with no boundaries.
Insecure man.
Insecure men.
You say they would seek that
intentionally.
Yes. Yes. Let me tell you why. There's
been a fundamental neglect of their
feminine needs point. But that is not an
excuse to as a female to go out and
treat your husband in such a way.
If you come from the Pakistani
background, they don't really talk about
anything like what happens at home or if
they've got any problems. Why are you
talking? If they go to their family,
don't talk about your husband like that.
You know what I mean?
To raise a concern in that area of the
marriage would automatically make you
feel as a man emasculated and therefore
there's a fear to address it.
If you are asking me these questions, if
you are unsatisfied, that must mean
you've had prior experience.
Wow.
And that was her first marriage.
So, closing remarks, why women cheat?
Um, I don't know.
Defend against the rapid spread of
myoplasma pneumonia aka white lung
disease using black resins. Siligit
packed with immune boosting properties.
Silagit has been scientifically proven
to promote respiratory health, aiding in
oxygen absorption while also making the
body infection resistant. Strengthen
your family's immune system ahead of the
new outbreak this winter.
Don't forget to use my discount code Ali
Dawa for 15% off. Enjoy.
Brothers and sisters and dear friends,
welcome to another episode of the Bitter
Trip Show. Inshallah. Hope you guys are
well. Um I think it's been one year
since we started the Bit Trip Show. I
think it was in December. Uh but
brothers and sisters inshallah hope hope
this the show has benefited you guys. Uh
we're trying to understand each other
better. Uh of course we have evidence
from the Quran and Sunnah. Sometimes we
give our opinions as well. There is
nothing wrong with giving our opinions
as long as it's permissible. It's halal.
Um which is important as well. If you
would like to be a a panelist you can
apply at the bitter truth
show@gmail.com.
[clears throat] We film usually once a
month. Uh so if you want to apply you
can. Um and before I start I want to
praise Allah subhanaa tala the most
merciful the most just or praise his
glory and gratitude belong to him. Um
and we're going to get straight into it.
Today's topic is a little bit
controversial but again it is very
important for us to understand dynamics
the inner works the hard wiring of both
men and women when it comes to these
matters. Uh only then I think these
things will improve us cuz I think the
biggest thing that we lack is men don't
understand women and women don't
understand men. If we understand each
other better we can get along uh
inshallah in a much peaceful way. So
today's topic is quite controversial but
it is the topic of why men and women
become disloyal. Yeah. So we want to
know what causes a woman to go down the
route of disloyalty. What causes a man
to go down the route of disloyalty? And
then again we need to define from a
man's perspective what is disloyalty. Uh
because in Islam obviously a man is
allowed to marry more than one wife. So
some may deem that to be disloyalty. But
in the in the sight of Allah subhanaa
tala that man on yak has nothing on him
except if he has oppressed one wife over
the other which one of the hadith of the
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him he
said that man will come on the day of
judgment reclining on one side because
he favored one over the other. Uh it is
a serious topic. It's an important
topic. So yes, let's start off with um
why women because men it seems like men
can be culprits in that sense where you
know and we know from the hadith that
the biggest fna for a man or that hit B
is women. Um and we know like you know
many instances in the Quran and the
Sunnah that you know it is our biggest
weakness. We'll come into we'll come to
that in a minute. But let's start off
with um [clears throat] should we start
off with the brothers? Why men are why
women are disloyal or should we go to
the sisters maybe from their perspective
or sisters?
Let's go to the sisters. Okay. So
sisters. So what leads a woman? So in in
a nutshell obviously we [clears throat]
as men we know ourselves. We can talk
about what leads a man. But what would
you say is the causes that leads? And by
the way just a quick disclaimer um this
obviously is something that is haram. it
is something that is is a major sin um
in that sense where there's a capital
punishment and we know what the capital
punishment is I don't need to go into
detail um and also um just something to
touch upon there was a woman at the time
of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam who came to the prophet Mam
peace be upon him and said that I
committed this act and the prophet
wasallam refused to accept it from her
and just you know just ignored ignored
until she was like look I have done this
and then she said okay he said you are
pregnant or once you've give birth come
back so the prophetam was trying to tell
her look just repent in a in a nutshell
you don't have to go through
She gave birth and she still came and
she was she the capital of punishment
applied to her which was stoning and she
um once this happened some of the blood
blood actually spluttered on one of the
companions feet and he kind of looked at
in a despised way and the prophetam said
the repentance that she did now is
sufficient enough for I think he said
the whole of Medina so we might look at
that person and despise them and no in
the sight of Allah what she did was so
in in like something that to be
praiseworthy that she went down that to
be cleansed in this life that the
prophet said her repentance will be
enough for Medina. Yeah. So these people
people can fall into this. We don't look
down upon them. We ask Allahh
but to know it's also a major major sin
inshallah. Um so let's start off with
let's say dopamine. This is dopamine. um
what causes a woman to go down the route
of thinking about disloyalty and also
from a woman's perspective does
disloyalty come just by argument say
committing zena or is disloyalty for a
woman starts emotionally
I would say emotionally first um but in
my personal opinion two reasons um one
being neglect if you got a loving caring
wife and she's not a jinabel okay so the
other one's she's just a shaitana she
wants to do haram she's not in love with
you. But the first one is neglecting
your wife. If you neglect your wife and
you give her not a lot of attention and
you don't pay attention to her, the way
she beautifies herself for you, the way
she cooks for you, the way she respects
you, then she's going to go elsewhere.
She's going to try to seek that from
some other guy or some other outlet. Um,
and then the second one is she's just a
Gabbel and someone who's seeking to do
she's a toxic female Geneabelle. She
wants to go and have illicit illegal
relationships with other men and she
doesn't love you because for a woman to
do that in my opinion again if a woman
cheats on a man like in a you know has
intimate relationships with another man
she doesn't love the man she's done it
to sorry
so the first puzzle of the day I
congratulate [laughter] you may Allah
bless you inshallah so you have one and
a half minutes I'm going to time you now
nobody can interrupt him your time
starts now
okay um alhamdulillah
It shouldn't take that long. Um before
we begin, um I think it's very I want to
understand how you're defining the word
disloyal. What is emotional cheating and
otherwise? Because um to be honest, I I
don't understand what you're talking
about.
Okay, straight to the point. Okay. What
do you define as disloyal? Can you give
us some demonstrate like what do you
disloy emotional perspective? Can
you tell us what what is
Yeah, tell tell us what's emotional
disloyalty. emotional change.
Tell tell us the stages a woman.
It can happen in different stages. Like
for instance, let's just take a woman
who goes to work and her husband's like
I said there's two reasons why a woman
may step out of her marriage emotionally
or physically. And the first said if you
neglect her rights, okay, which is
giving her attention, taking you know
care of how you speak to her and how she
looks when she beautifies herself.
You're not you're neglecting your wife.
So she'll then start to probably meet or
speak to other guys. She'll find an
outlet. She'll find an outlet. I don't
know what way but she'll probably start
talking to another person through
texting at work
and college is
is there a specific protocol should I
say they take like for example it starts
with for example wanting attention from
a coworker and then from there is there
a specific process women take cuz for
men I we can talk about that but what is
it like it starts from emotional
I wouldn't personally know cuz I've
never cheated on someone but but let me
just say
if I was to be a sit in a situation like
that remember what I said, we're looking
for the man to pay us attention. If it's
not paying us attention, we can go to
any outlet and try to seek that
attention. Whether it's going online,
posting pictures, going and and doing
just like crazy stuff just to seek
attention from another male because it's
not happening at home. So, if the
woman's at work, like I said, she could
be getting attention from male um
colleagues if she's in college, a teach,
a tutor, who whatever it may be. But I
don't know how it may start off. But
that's what I'm saying. the outlets are
there and if she's not getting the
attention at home, she's going to go and
seek it elsewhere.
So,
okay. So,
I hope that made sense.
So, go ahead.
Um, I I understand what you're saying.
Um,
so
when you say emotional cheating, um, I'm
not I still don't know what that means,
per se, but what you're saying is the
act of cheating.
I didn't say emotional cheating, by the
way. I don't I don't know where that
came from in a sense, bro. Like, for
example, like argument sake, she can be
going and putting stuff on Instagram.
Yeah.
And with attention to get attention from
the other
not even that like emotional
just one one
a guy just sorry babe let me just let me
just say emo okay I think I know what
you mean about emotional cheating like
it's not physical right but if a a woman
is interacting with a man and I thought
about this the other day someone's
liking someone's pictures right is that
class cheating as well because you're
actually looking at the person you're
lusting over them I don't know but
emotionally a woman is everything's
emotional and mental for us anyway so if
a guy acts as our accesses are mental
and he starts texting or talking to you,
that would be for me class as emotional
cheating.
That's fine. In that sense, maybe move
the discussion on a bit. So, are you
saying from the way you kind of
presented it, it's kind of like uh the
man's uh prerogative for why this
happened?
Absolutely.
To what extent does the woman take
responsibility for that cheating?
For the crime that she's commit.
Yeah. One thing that I noticed that I
don't know like just general, by the
way, we're talking about let's talk
about third person, woman, men and not
ours. Yeah. Um I've noticed that anytime
a woman is caught it's your fault like
he should I don't know if this is I've
seen this a lot like you watch the
certain Instagram videos etc where she
would be like it's because of you like
what you said now which um there is a
whole like phenomena about women don't
like taking accountability but basically
in a nutshell emotional cheating is bro
the emotional things that she wants from
you the attention you do not give it she
replaces with someone else so she's
cheating it's not in the physical sense
it's in the emotional sense she expects
that from you you do not give it to her
she will find it somewhere else
why can't she do that anyway without get
even if she receives received it from
her husband.
No, she can. But she's saying here that
for example, it's sufficient from the
husband. If the husband doesn't give it,
she would go and seek it elsewhere. So
the cheating is not necessarily
committing zer, which cheating in Islam
is zena is penetration [clears throat]
happening. We're not talking about that.
We're talking about for example
emotional neglect. She's like, I will go
and fulfill that via my friends, zoned
individuals or other people, my tutor,
whoever is for that matter who's telling
me nice things, things that I crave, I
get it from that person. Basically,
basically obviously as a provider as a
provider you provide not just f the
financial needs and whatever you you
also provide the emotional need. That's
a basic necessity especially for a
woman.
But if she's not getting that home, it's
a it's a natural it's a natural need.
It's a it's a basic need. It's a human
need for her. So she will naturally
without obviously like intentionally
wanting to [clears throat] she will seek
it out. Let's say let's say let's say
she's working and it's a male colleague
rather than confiding in you as a
husband.
She confides in her male colleague
confides in her male colleague and says
look I'm going through this. I'm going
through that. And then he says oh it's
okay. I'm I'm going to be here for you.
that that specifically that that and
then so then eventually they build a
connection because she's now now she's
got her outlet because her husband's
neglected her for a while and that
outlet is her colleague scenario per se.
Um and she goes to him on a regular
basis. It's not cheating the first time
but then now she's going to him on a
regular basis. I've going I'm going
through this and I'm going through I
feel like this and this is what's
happened in my life. Um and and I need
you. I need you. And that's when it
becomes emotional cheating. She's
cheating
depend on another man for her emotional
needs. Yeah. Does that make sense?
So not physical. There could be a man
who's physically pleasing her but
emotionally the guy is not there. He's
absent. Yeah. But this can lead to the
physical cheating as well. They can
start off because they build that
connection with each other. Do we do you
disagree with that?
Yeah. But just to go back again, you ask
the question. All right. So, I deal with
the question.
You asked me what why a woman would
cheat. And it's because you neglect her
emotional needs. You neglecting her in
that way. So, when you said, "Oh, is it
the brother's fault?" Yeah. And the
brother will be called to account if his
wife actually does go out and cheat on
him because you shouldn't be neglecting
her in that way and she's going to go
and seek it somewhere else.
True. or she she she would obviously in
this obviously we're talking in general
terms as well but general terms she um
uh I don't think it gives her her reason
to do that for example she can say you
know what this man man is not
emotionally satisfying me and I would
like a divorce because I fear that I
will go and do something haram so I
don't think because [clears throat]
women tend to run away from
accountability but in this instance I
don't think she can run away from this
in the sense where if that is the case
yes you can talk this man is not given
I've communicated to him I've talked to
him I need this I'm trying to vent out
you're not going to be there for me then
instead of going to the direction
because Allah says in the Quran taklab
was in I don't even come near to it
coming near to is having co friends etc
male friends in that for the get- go
anyways so I would say we can't read
accountability and blame the man she has
responsibility you don't like it divorce
him go get married to someone that gives
emotional but there is there is okay I I
get what you're saying I 100% get what
you're saying um at the end of the day
doesn't matter what what how much he
neglects her the fact that she committed
the act herself the responsibility does
come down to her
we're not saying that she's not respons
she is responsible but then the man als
but the man also he also plays a level
of responsibility in that they're both
they both the reason why she went and
emotionally cheated which eventually
let's say led to physical cheating was
the fact that she was being ne her
emotions were being neglected in the
first the source the source was was the
fact that her emotional needs weren't
being met
on on that basis though um it's
important to point out that it's a man's
validation because everything you guys
mentioned um she could get it from a
female, right? [snorts] So also there
must be it's not the same.
She can't she can't
if she can't again my experience is
limited in this sense but if a woman can
get emotional support from a woman um
but she's trying to get it from a man.
What's the difference between the
emotional support a man provides
compared to a woman that a woman and a
man cannot be in it is different which
we're going to find out now.
Two women can't be in a relationship.
Another thing before we come to the
brothers is also sister Gaz and in
sister Pervine
um Fahana
sister Fahana sorry I get the sister
mixed up mixed up. So um also would you
say that the lack of masculinity in a
man does it also lead a woman to be
disloyal a lack of masculinity it's very
important can we have you two touch upon
it please inshallah so a lack of
masculinity does this lead to a man
because by your nature you want a man
that's a leader provider someone
masculine when that lags does that play
a role in pushing or like you know
despise that man like
um I would say personally it it's not
the reason I feel a woman would kind of
move away from that relationship ship
because of a lack of masculinity. There
is a level of patience and support that
we try to go through to before that
becomes the be all and end all. But I
don't actually think that. Um I think
first and foremost it's really important
to clarify for me like I feel that um
men cheating and women cheating starts
off very differently and the motives
start off very differently. For example,
um I would say that females
the the the cheating process starts when
she disconnects herself from her
husband. So there has to be an element
of disconnect first before she then has
the idea of seeking the validation or
the emotions from someone else. Whereas
I feel with males the cheating starts
it's not they don't need to disconnect
from the existing wife to then form
another connection. whereas females do.
And so it is quite a long process. It's
not just something that happens on a
whim. Um you know it's it's actually you
know females fight. I don't have
experience by the registered disclaimer,
but I'm just getting into to our psych
um you know why that could happen is
that it is a long process of
disconnecting and it it's got to be a a
succession of disappointments that the
the husband has demonstrated towards her
before she gets to the point of seeking
um compassion or attention or love or
validation from someone else. So I feel
like it's a more of a serious journey
for when females end up in that um
compromised situation than when it does
for males. And this is why I also feel
that um women generally are more
forgiving of males um cheating than
women because we understand inherently
that a woman's actually gone through a
whole long process of disconnect before
that if the if it ends up into a
physical act
that before she even got to that
position. I also believe that for the
most part if it does get to the physical
um aspect for a woman that she's had to
battle a lot or is actually feeling
stuck actually in that relationship that
didn't allow her to just leave the
marriage to then pro you know proceed
with another relationship because in my
mind if you were if I was ever going to
feel that way that's the process I would
take I wouldn't resort to that it would
just be end the relationship ship, you
know, marry someone else, that's it. But
for
for that to happen, something
fundamentally must be wrong in her life
opportunities
in the existing marriage for for that to
kind of coincide with the marriage that
acts to um overlap with having a husband
and having um I don't know what to call
him, a lover, side person.
It's [laughter] not even a side thing.
It's a totally different.
It's not because you guys are monogous
by nature.
You know, sis, I I get you know what you
just you've explained that so
beautifully that there is a mental
process that goes behind it. But I was
just going to I wanted to touch up on
what brother Ali Dawa said about the
lack of respect. There are some women
out there who have like a certain type
of personality, specifically
narcissistic personality types. They
usually will seek out a man who is very
kind and gentle and considerate and over
like giving with no boundaries.
Um and he doesn't he kind of lacks a
backbone in um standing up for himself
and
women
insecure insecure man.
Insecure men.
You say they would seek that
intentionally.
Yes. Yes. Let me tell you why. Let me
tell you there's
that guy would never be the main guy. He
just
they narcissistic women specifically
will seek out these type of women
because that man will provide. He will
provide and he will bend over backwards
for her. He's giving her basic
necessities that she needs so she
doesn't have to work. She doesn't need
need to do all those things. Um and he's
very overgiving while she goes and does
her thing. There's there are women out
there who will take advantage of w men
who
are you described as insecure but like
yeah in to a to to a certain to a
certain extent
they say they would seek to marry these
men.
Yes there there are women there are
women who will seek to marry these type
of men because of the advantages that
comes with it but then also the fact
that they can do what they want to do.
So we're going to we're going to go to
brother Sat and Matthew as well but we
need to really understand these
dynamics. We need to listen to our
sisters very carefully because this is
the dynamics of of of a woman. They're
hypogous by nature. And if there's
certain things that they can't they
can't find in that perfect man, they
would it's it's it's like they would
have it's like something um
it's it's temporary until you find the
one, you know, it's it's most times. But
Sage and then brother Matthew. So I I
have a lot of experience with seeing
women cheating on their partners because
the places are working and I kind of see
like married women or women in
relationships. They come out uh they got
husbands at home and they come out and
maybe go with someone else or do things
and that. But the main thing comes from
this is is the situation starts at home.
if the man is not like doing his part at
home or listening to them or doing
certain things. But a lot of women will
pick on these little things to make
excuses for themselves. Okay. So the
things we have to understand that it's
not all the time this problem that the
man is not uh ticking all the boxes. Now
sometimes he does tick all the boxes but
they still will find a problem to kind
of do certain things to make excuses for
their actions. Okay. But the thing is
the main thing is in Islamic in in our
Muslim community if it happens is she's
not she's not getting what she wants at
home and when she goes out outside gets
it from someone else and it's hard for a
woman to do that but but then but then
starts from a conversation someone
showing that interest in her or being
there for her and she when she goes home
the husband is too busy he might not
even know it he's doing this
and the thing is a lot of time women
need to talk to their husband to say
look um I need to talk to you need to
listen to me you know I got this problem
but sometimes they won't have that
communication then she will go off start
talking to someone starts a conversation
then slowly slowly lead to zah and this
is how it starts off so I think
I'm going to disagree with that
okay you've got one and a half minutes
starting now
I feel like women are very vocal and I
don't feel that any woman just cheats
willy-nilly you know it's not just
something you do on the side like I feel
maybe the male biology can much
naturally easily um do. Um also you also
have to question whether the man sold
her a lie and maybe that's why she's
become unhappy. What have you sold her
the marriage to be? Maybe at the
beginning you know it was all lovely and
you know you had promises and dreams and
etc. Maybe life has come in the way and
you've both slowed down, you know, in in
achieving those objectives or those
things that you had passion for, but
someone along the way has um been
neglectful. We go back to that word. But
it it's not a very easy process to just
go to work, get a bit of attention from
males. I mean, we've all been to work,
you know, for many years. And of course,
females get attention and in in between
we've been married, you know, we've had
children and it doesn't mean that
because someone else has given me
attention that I'm going to latch on to
that just very easily. Like something
fundamental has to have broken down in
the relationship. Can I
can I can I can I go to meth before we
can I just land this please? I think I
don't
please don't get me wrong. I have to
mention this because it people don't
talk about it. incompetency in the
bedroom. Excuse me everyone. I'm sure we
all adults in here, but that could also
be another deciding factor. A lot of
people don't talk about it. There's men
that have issues. Do you know what I
mean? There's things going on and I'm
just I have to mention it before the
viewers because people may be suffering
with this at home because this is a big
problem that we shy away from that we
need to talk about%
and I just feel like it's worth
mentioning that there is incompetency
and women sometimes they don't know how
to articulate that and they may actually
feel like okay I can't articulate it.
It's just I'm not saying it will and I'm
not just Yeah. And I'm not justifying
cheating for a woman, but if she goes
and cheats after that, but I just have
to mention it that that could
potentially be over a period of time if
you're not communicating as a man and
you're not working together to fix that
problem. She could eventually feel like,
you know, he's not opening up. He's not
letting me know what's going on.
[clears throat] And then some other guy
comes along.
It is it is it is her right. And
Islamically, like the reason I started
this show is we need to be open about
this stuff. We want solutions. I I had a
forgive me. I had an ad. It's called um
forgive me. It's It says specific. Yeah.
It's got it's Xiagra or something like
that. Yeah. And people are you're a DA
guy. How could you?
I'm like, what the I'm I'm just
thinking, are you on this planet Earth?
It is halal. By the way, I've spoken to
a lot of mash. Yeah. There are brothers
who are watching pornography. Yeah. And
they have erectile erectile dysfunction.
Bro, they can't please their wives. This
is a real issue. This is a real issue
and it needs to be discussed about. And
people like, you're a da guy. Wait, what
are you talking about? It's a real
problem and it's the woman's huck. This
is this not it is the woman's huck. She
has every right to ask for divorce if
she is not sexually pleased. This is
Islam. You got a problem, brother. Go
follow what you want. We follow Islam.
It is a woman's huck to say I am not
happy. And actually this this happened
at the time of the prophet if I'm not
mistaken. A woman came and said I am not
sexually satisfied. It's [laughter] her.
What are you gonna say? Oh, it's it's
rude. She came to the messenger of
Allah. The prophet
they praised the unsari woman for being
so transparent with these matters.
I want to say the thing is one thing
about especially it comes from the
culture side that people don't
communicate a lot.
So if they have a problem at home and
sister when I said about the cheating
thing I was talking it from the
westernist side western views and that
because I work on the door so I see
certain things that a lot of people
don't see. So the thing is what I'm
saying is that people don't communicate
because what kind of backgrounds like if
you come from the Pakistani background
they don't really talk about anything
like that. What happens at home or if
they've got any problems while you
talking if they go to their family don't
talk about your husband like that. You
know what I mean? And they're really
locked in. So what they do they're one
trying to find escape.
Yeah.
And and they come to a stage that they
can't talk to anyone and they're trying
to find escape. And that's when all of
this happens. How can a woman prevent
that from happening? I wanted to re I
wanted to
I wanted to add to what you were saying
the there's also like a element of
shame. So for example, let's say a woman
is not satisfied in the bedroom. Uh and
let's say they come from like a a maybe
a strict cultural background. Uh and the
h the wife does address it to the
husband that he will shame her. He'll be
oh it's your fault like you can't be
satisfied. Like, but but you're the man
who you're not I'm not trying to be like
crude or anything, but you're the one
who's performing.
Uh and you're the one who's performing.
You're the one who's providing uh and if
she's telling you, hey, look, I'm not
satisfied. Can we try something
different? Can we do something
different? But then you turn around and
say um like how dare you have these
needs and um and then shame her for
having a question basic human needs to
for her to just be satisfied. If if
you're shaming her, then then you're
just closing up that topic of
conversation and then she automatically
now doesn't want to even talk to you
about it. Can I just add
Can I just ask a question? I'll pass it
over to Mai. Um I understand a lot of
what you guys have said and obviously um
it's your opinion. It's how you feel
it's valid. Um and a lot of it from my
perspective is you know a woman's been
driven to that point which perhaps is
the case. So from a female perspective
obviously as men we'll take
accountability to kind of prevent that
inshallah from happening. But so from a
female perspective, what could she have
done to prevent that disengagement from
happening from the husband and kind of
mitigate um her the fact that she's not
being satisfied in the bedroom? What
could she do to kind of support her
husband in these matters?
It depends though because it just all
depends on the scenario, right? I just
feel feel like it all depends. What
could she do to prevent it? Depends why
there's incompetency in the bedroom. Is
it a medical issue? Is it something you
can work on? Is it something you need to
get viagra for? Is it something you need
to see a doctor? Is it is it porn? What
is the issue? So again, it's all about
communication. If you're not
communicating, that's why I said if
there is incompetent issues in the
bedroom, then the man and the woman are
not communicating. They don't want to
work towards like healing and fixing the
issue, then unfortunately they have
cases where people are cheating, you Can
I just add just out of curiosity or I
mean there's an element that informs my
question here um from a sister that I've
known um to have had a similar
experience. Um the assumption is I think
for maybe a lot of female minds is that
to raise a concern in that area of the
marriage would automatically make you
feel as a man emasculated and therefore
there's a fear to address it. So perhaps
this is the barrier that's preventing
that communication and then to if you're
saying that no it doesn't emasculate for
some reason we have that idea maybe
there there was a scenario of a sister
that addressed it with her husband at
the time they were having issues and he
questioned why she had how she knew she
had a problem with that side of things
and he questioned her integrity and her
whole um you know what happened before
they got married and he completely
flipped it and said that if you are
asking me these questions if you are
unsatisfied that must mean you've had
prior experience
wow
and that was her first marriage you know
so clearly he's suggesting something
awful [clears throat] so I think maybe
there's a fear of from the female side
there's a fear of these kinds of
reactions
um
I think that's a very good point there
has to be there has to be a thin line
Because the biggest emasculation for a
man should be that your wife goes and be
sleeps with another man. So for that
matter, I think men should be grown-ups
and be like, I rather be emasculated by
my wife communicating to me what I'm not
doing rather than me pushing her to a
level where I'm emasculated by knowing
that she was with another man. So men
should mature up. Another issue that you
said in this matter go to Matthew as
well is you're right, brothers are very
sensitive when it comes to the past of
their wives. We've discussed this. Why
does virginity matter for a men? For
man. Watch that episode inshallah. talk
in detail to understand our psychology
where we come from those things do
trigger men in the sense of oh you want
me to do that but oh is it cuz he so
it's a very fine balance but let's get
back to topic in which is Matthew you've
been quite quiet I think you've been
assessing maybe the whole room and the
situation at hand um
some excellent points have been raised
so we can categorize now the two types
of cheating that the sisters have raised
as the emotional sort or the physical
sort or maybe even both is going on okay
a sister could be emotionally satisfied
but not intimately satisfied and she can
potentially cheat. Okay. Vice versa as
well. She could be physically satisfied
but not emotionally satisfied and cheat.
Although sex is very much like a glue.
And if she's intimately satisfied, she's
less likely to step out on you than if
she is emotionally satisfied. [snorts]
And that's why I would say like your
duty as a man just to quote actually I'm
stealing this quote from Abu American.
Shout out to him. Your duty as a man is
to alpha widow your woman within the
first two three months. Meaning she is
the best intimate experience.
Okay?
Either she's ever had if she was married
before or she's completely satisfied
with you if she has not been married
before. Now the sisters also raised
another excellent point which is that a
brother or a man, it's not even a Muslim
thing will absolutely feel emasculated
if his woman said to him um uh you know
I'm not intimately satisfied. and
navigating that mindfield. Bro, that's a
mad one. How do I tell my husband I'm
not intimately satisfied without him
doing an uno reverse card on me and
putting it back on me and saying, "Uh,
you know, maybe you've got prior
experience and whatnot." And as much as
I agree with you, Akali, when you say he
needs the emasculation of her stepping
out is worse than the emasculation of
her saying that.
Yeah, bro. But that's the hard one to
hear your wife tell you.
It is. It is.
Like you just you feel like a zero, bro.
Do you understand? But but rather than
like focusing on the fact that oh um I
feel emasculated in this moment cuz my
wife just told me I'm not she's not I'm
not satisfying her is rather than
focusing on that why don't you focus on
the fact that okay my wife's just come
with the fact that she has a need and
the need is that she needs to be
satisfied
you need to have compassion
exactly compassion and the ones that you
guys actually failed miserably
[laughter] to
I mean look to answer your question it
depends it Maybe he can do better, maybe
he can't. Let me just be perfectly frank
here, okay? If she's been married
before, I understand. But I'm just being
frank here. And this is why men have
such an aversion to women who do have
prior sexual experience. Whether it's in
halal or not, honestly, it's not
relevant. Majority of men have an
aversion to women who have prior because
he knows that she's going to be
comparing. I did a polygyny Q&A live on
my wife's channel the other day. The one
most common question I got from the
sisters was, "Will he compare me with
the new wife?" And I said, "Sister, do
you know why you're asking that
question? Cuz that's how you that's
[clears throat] how that's how you do
that." Cuz that's how you assess. So you
can understand the aversion that men
have that. I'm not saying it's right or
wrong or whatever. I'm just stating it
as it is.
Now,
with regards to what the sister do said
with regards to he's going to be
accountable if she does step out. I will
reject that and I'll explain explain to
you why. Ali mentioned the ayah at the
beginning of the podcast very poignantly
which is where Allah says and don't go
anywhere near Zena.
No, not zena.
I'm coming. I'm coming. I'm coming.
I'll let you land your bow 77.
So if Yeah, let me land the plane.
[laughter]
So So if she is feeling this way and she
has attempted to communicate it to him
and you know she's exhausted all avenues
and for whatever it's not happening just
as a pointed out
is that it is a legitimate reason for a
divorce if you've exhausted all other
avenues first. Not
but for her to not do that and instead
go down the haram route that's 100% on
her. Even if he's not, even if he's not
act, he's not saying you are. I'm not
saying you are. I'm just saying even if
he's in error, even if he's denying, oh,
what's wrong with you? Even if he's like
trying to do a uno reverse on you,
doesn't matter. That sin is still on
you.
That word uno reverse,
that sin that sin is still on the sister
because okay, he made his from a from a
from a sin perspective. He messed up.
Fine. But you must take that full
account. So I'd say to solutions, we
want solutions, right? If a sister finds
herself in that situation, she needs to
find a way. Men are dumb for the most
part when it comes to picking up on your
covert communication strategies.
Exactly.
They don't get it.
They don't understand. They don't get
hieroglyphics.
Now you're caught between two dilemas.
The dilemma of covert communication and
the dilemma of if I'm direct,
he's going to feel emasculated. Which
one do I choose? This is where hikma
comes in.
I don't know. Maybe you speak with his
father and somebody of authority who can
speak to him in a particular manner.
There has to be some hikma here. You see
in the delivery of the message.
Isn't that more emasculating if the wife
was I didn't say do that. I said I was
just giving an example off the cuff of
potential ways you could approach this
discussion. Just as when the old man was
making
and one of the grandsons of Hassan and
Hussein
and they to show him how to do wudoo
properly they didn't tell him they said
they taught each other look this is how
you do your woo and the old man picked
up on it
absolutely I agree with everything you
said but doesn't it to sorry sorry Ali
doesn't it depend on how how you
approach doesn't it depend on what type
of cheating we're talking about because
we've we've we've clearly seen that
there's two types of cheating women do
right emotional cheating which I feel
like most the women most likely are
going to do that cheating to get
physical as said it's very it's very
very very not likely. You mentioned in
the western society that's [snorts] most
likely going to happen but as Muslims if
we want to talk about emotional cheating
I think it's best to stick to that. I
think that's fine to communicate to your
husband if you feel like he's
emotionally absent. I feel like that's
easy. I feel like a man should be able
to communicate with his wife and she
should be able to communicate with him
if he's emotionally unavailable. I think
I think so. I think I would
that wouldn't deasculate a man.
Yeah, I think [laughter] I think I think
if a wife would you agree other
if he does then you he's got a lot of
competency in the bedroom. Now that's
Yeah. Let's talk about stuff. For
example,
let's say for example the woman says I
haven't tried this like like can like
the impression even if she has a past
it's very important. Wording is very
important. Yeah. Just be like you know
what I've never tried this like can we
do it for the first time? I think these
wording like for example because going
to someone else talking directly is a
problem indirectly can be a problem
maybe just saying you know what for
example can we try this today
yeah I've never experienced this like
can we do this today or let's try that
or
are we talking about physical stuff
yes she's intimacy I write intimacy bro
I wouldn't even say it I just tell her
just do it
don't she's asking the issue is this if
do what she's asking you
she's asking she's she wants something
she's asking and saying can we try So
this comes down to hikma. Now I said you
got to be so careful when approaching
this with with most men cuz it's going
to be all like bro that's like
[laughter]
I think it will break a man.
But but there are ways to do it. You can
still get what you want. You just have
to be smart about it. So instead of
outright telling
that's a secret ladies only learn. I
feel after a while
right
and that's why you guys are better at
the art of covert communication than we
are in the first instance.
No, there's a way to
there's a way of approaching
approach things as a as a woman when
you're in a relationship with a man
and it's it's like a secret gem that
comes after a while. I feel like it
doesn't come naturally. I don't think it
comes naturally. I feel like over the
time after experience being married for
so long, you you realize how to deal
with the man and how to get things from
him.
Can I throw a spanner into the works? I
want to throw a spanner into the works.
Yeah.
I [snorts] personally believe Okay. And
again, this is from my experience and
the men that I know. If there is an
emotional need or a sexual need, if you
express that to your partner, if he's a
male, it doesn't emasculate the man.
I personally feel that way.
Really?
Yeah, I really do. I don't think it's
It depends on what kind of man.
It depends on the individual.
Let's talk about majorities, [laughter]
not exceptions to the rule. There's
exceptions to the rule. Most men, bro,
they would feel insecure. But how do you
ascertain that?
I feel like it's the exceptions that are
causing the issues. So what we want to
do is there's there's exceptions to the
rule. Yeah. So there's there's a general
like 99% of men, 99% of women and then
there are those 1% exceptions for
example. Yeah. So what I'm saying in
that nutshell is that let's let's talk
about the general because there are
exceptions. There might be a a man who
says you know I have no problem if my
wife comes and speaks about uh her past
and well good for you. Yeah. So um yeah
I would say let's talk for solutions in
that aspect.
You know what it is is it do you know
why a man would have a problem with it?
It feels like a direct criticism to his
performance.
It depends. So say for example, if if
for example the man has a need to be the
leader and I feel as though if in that
relationship
he knows that if this criticism is
thrown at him, it doesn't take away from
his manhood, it won't necessarily be a
problem.
But that's a man who's secure.
What I say, what I say is depend how you
approach it. So if your woman goes to
you, you don't perform properly, that's
going to deasculate you. But if she goes
to you that let's try something
different or you can do this in this way
let's try something let's do this or my
friends done this let me and you try it
out. So the thing is you you approach it
in a way that you don't dis well like
you know you don't
attack the man
you don't attack the man but you kind of
approach it in a different way but if
you go straight at him of course he's
going to
the topic has gone to the topic of
intimacy this topic of why women
understand by the way I'm going to make
the whole episode on this because we
need a whole episode for the men which
we'll do next time
can I ask a question we've got 30
minutes so let's stick to the topic of
I want to genuinely ask a question about
the emotional what can men do
um that will prevent women from being um
why are men so emotionally unavailable?
Bon and what can men do to stop women
from actually going out and cheating on
them emotionally?
Good, good, good. What can we do to
I'll go first. Yeah. Um I'll reject that
claim. You said men un uh generally
that's not true. Some men perhaps what
can they do? I think it depends on the
relationships. I don't think this
sorry I I I didn't understand that
because I said what can men do and we
are talking about men and women right?
Yeah but um
you want me to put Muslim men.
No no no you said uh why are men
emotionally unavailable?
Yeah they are tend to be emotionally
unavailable.
I think she's saying
in the terms you're saying some men
No no no we're talking about cheating
right so we we we talking about
cheating. Yeah we're talking about
cheating. So why we already acknowledged
that
so we're talking about the men that are
cheating. Yeah. The women who are on the
men who are those specific men
neglecting a woman emotionally will
answer that answer um I think depends on
the relationship and I don't know
the thing is like if you know your wife
you'll pick up on the body language.
Yes.
How she acts how she is.
But if you don't know your wife then
it's going to be a big problem because
with men we can't read women like
that's why they need to study the mental
stri. This is what I mean that you have
to sometimes we we like so busy in this
world thinking about how to repay the
rent or how to do this how to do that
thinking about other things and you know
it doesn't come to our head
you know you know you know one one thing
like that tell me if I'm right or wrong
here yeah um the reason why sisterh
Gizlane talked about being um first you
have to detach from him this is because
you woman are monogous by nature you are
happy with one man but he has to be a
man once you're happy with that man you
will not look anywhere else I believe
this 100% if That man is the man you
will never ever even think about it.
That's the reason why when we talk about
polygamy, you guys bug out cuz you're
like this is how I see him. But he
doesn't see me the same because we don't
think like you. For us men, even if we
had the most drop dead gorgeous woman on
this planet earth, we can tend to want
other women. Do you get what I'm trying
to say? So in that aspect answering the
question coming back to before brothers
and sisters go here, we got Ali again
with this polygamy. Going back to this
issue is this. If a man is there for his
wife, protect, provide. That's the basic
dean on dean by the way praying etc. But
you have to be expressive. I genuinely
say this you have to be expressive with
your wife. Even if it's lying brother
it's white as the prophet is allowed.
Yeah. Touching look hearing look let her
hear and let her feel your love. It's
very important to even if like I said
before waking up in the morning etc like
like and again I'm a nobody. I'm not
trying to boast like I'm someone, but I
try to be expressive with my wife. She's
a co-producer of this. She's here and
I'm not saying it because anything that
I say in the back of it, if I'm not
doing, she'll be like, "So, this guy's
lying." She knows. I'm trying to I try
to be expressive. And even in the
morning where the sisters might feel
like, you know, they look they don't
look their part. I just say, "Oh my
gosh, man, look at this beautiful woman
just walk in the room." It's it's it's
very important expressive touching for
example um intimately or not. It's very
important because I believe as men
that we have a big responsibility. Yeah.
And some brother I know a brother who
was his wife cheated on him. And I asked
him a simple question. I said bro just
want to understand few dynamics of your
marriage. Can you tell me a little bit
about it? He said bro I work 60 hours a
week this that I gave her whatever she
wanted. I said stop. I said rewind
please. He said I gave her whatever she
wanted. I said brother for me is anytime
for example sometimes if you takeick all
the boxes you untick all them. The
problem is this. When you give a woman
everything but there's no you're not at
home. Yeah. You give her whatever she
wants. I blame men. We as men are the
leaders and providers for a reason.
Allah has put put us over them for a
reason. And if you do not do your bit,
we're not saying justifying the cheating
of of the woman. But the point is this.
You do play a role in the sense of what
are you sinful? I don't know if you're
sinful. She's sinful if she does that.
But as a man, you have to do your bit.
Emotionally, you have to be there for
her. Yes. Physically, in the bedroom,
etc. You have to. And I promise you,
bro, if you do that, I genuinely believe
in a woman would never ever ever think
of another man. Maybe you guys elaborate
of that solutions wise. In
She wanted to say something.
Yeah.
Sure. Oh, yeah. Please.
Um I wanted to say um obviously to avoid
the cheating, you could uh go on dates
every week like every like every week is
like perfect or
Yeah. Perfect. Every week is perfect.
Yeah. So every week when you do that,
you're bonding emotionally. You're
getting to know each other. You're
talking. You're getting to know each
other's
your time. Like you time
quality time. Brilliant. Yeah.
Yeah.
When you do that,
your bond will grow stronger and then
you'll get to know your wife even more,
what she wants, and she she'll know what
you want.
I would like to probe sister dopamine if
that's okay. I noticed that this
discussion of emotional unavailability,
it brought out a visceral reaction
inside you. So maybe if you could
contextualize what you're explaining
with a specific story or maybe someone
that you know.
I didn't really get what you
emotionally unavailable.
Yeah. Emotional unavailability. So when
a man is emotionally unavailable, what
specific instance could you share with
us cuz then we could give you a more
specialized answer.
Men men in general, they get women so
confused. And I just recently put out a
video about our menstrual cycle and
sorry to be a bit TMI but we are an
emotional being. Do you understand? So
if you normal,
but if you if you look into our hormones
and how we are just unbalanced all the
time, up and down, up and down. If you
study this, then you've essentially
understood women. Do you understand? If
you understand that, then you're you're
good.
So
you will never be you'll never be
emotional, unavailable.
What you just said there is important
because their hormones are up and down.
That's why they're like chasing a woman
like chasing a shadow.
So this this [laughter]
how we are. You can't change that. No,
but I'll give you I'll give you the pen.
Hold on. Hold on. You can't change it.
Like if you can't change something, what
do you do? You You try to understand it.
Don't try to bend the woman cuz she's
going to break.
Yeah, she will break. Correct. Look,
I'm just saying
a man a man does need to invest
emotionally in his woman. Yeah.
He doesn't what?
He does need to invest in emotionally.
But attention is one of those
commodities that you need to treat with
caution
because if you give too much of it,
I agree.
She will the the value of it begins to
diminish.
I agree. And the now because again
there's loads of young guys watching
this and I'm more speaking to them when
I'm speaking to you guys. And the filter
generally is conduct your daily affairs.
Fear Allah subhana wa ta'ala to the best
of your ability. I'm talking to the men
now. Yeah.
And then work work hard. Work very hard.
And then after all of that I don't even
believe scheduled dates by the way. I
don't believe in none of that nonsense.
I tell you
I feel like that's preference wise.
I called my on Thursday night. I called
my wife up. I said listen I'm just
finished with work. I may or may not be
taking you up, but get your stuff ready
anyway. I hadn't even That's so
inconsistent. I need to know.
Exactly.
I feel like I feel like honestly
[laughter] saying I'm going to let you
finish landing. You're still hovering
over to go down.
No, she pressed it.
Oh, did you press it?
It was me.
Oh, you pressed it for her. Okay, you
got one and a half minutes starting now.
I hear what you're saying, but that's
your marriage and that's what works for
you and your wife.
No, it's not my marriage. We can't inter
I'm so sorry. We can't interrupt. 1 and
a half minute and then you
let me go 66 1 and 12 minute 1 and a2
minute sister go
um that's what works for you. Do you get
it? That's what works for you. So you
want to speak to your wife like that and
deal with her like that. That's
absolutely fine. You're compatible for
each other. But in general I don't that
that differs. Do you understand? That
differs. It doesn't mean that because
you think that's huck that that every
guy should be treating their wives like
that cuz everyone's different.
One minute. You got one minute.
Are you finished? Are you finished?
Yeah.
You got one minute. Have you finished?
I'm just trying to be just here. You got
one minute.
I can add to that. Can I add to the It's
your time. Have you got you got one
minute? Do you want to carry on?
Um, pass the bat.
Yeah, I'll pass the bat.
This reaction is [laughter]
this reaction is [clears throat] good
because again, I'm speaking to the there
is an inverse relationship between what
makes a woman happy and what makes her
desire you. Okay, I have a few wives,
alhamdulillah, not just one. And I can
tell you from my experience dealing with
women that there are some common traits
and themes that you'll see in all of
them. There is an inverse relationship
between her happiness and her desire for
you. The happier you make her, the less
she desires you. If there's a slight few
things that are annoying, just as you
just said, that's annoying. That would
annoy me. Yeah, that's that element of
unpredictability can be annoying, but it
keeps her attention because she just
doesn't know what's coming next. And
that is the spontaneity that you guys
speak of so often. I want my husband to
be spontaneous saying that I agree with
you. How about instead of saying, "Oh, I
phone your wife and say, "Oh, get we may
or may not be going out tonight, but get
ready anyway." I feel like that's a
little bit of a joke if I'm totally
honest.
You know, you're sitting here.
I would rather
Do you really do that, Matthew? One
second. Let me have a brother. One
second. One second. [laughter]
Is it Is it like that or is it Cuz you
remember last time there was some stuff
he was like, he actually wasn't like
that.
No, no, no. Look, look. I don't know. M.
Okay. Is it directly like that or is it
Yeah. So my normal bar, it depends on
which wife I'm going to go out with, but
my normal bar is I'm going to be with
you in half an hour. Get ready. We're
going. That's my normal bar.
Okay, good. Spont. Okay. So it's not
Look, listen, you need to understand,
it's not 5 minutes.
Exactly. Exactly. So it's basic
for example, he just finished work. He
would tell his wife, maybe the wife is,
oh, I wish you gave me some more time.
But you know, deep down she likes to,
you know what? Oh my gosh. Like, you
know, in 30 minutes, let me just get
up since we're not going out.
Sorry. No, no, no. Just I repeat again.
He said what he meant was this. Like he
finished work and he would say, "Listen,
get ready in 30 minutes. We're going
out." He wouldn't say, "We're going out
or not." Maybe.
No, he did say that.
No. Then then I [laughter] told I didn't
say that.
No, he did say that. Then I said to him,
"Clarify." And then he said,
"At least one thing I will I've I've
noticed is that they're getting
attention from you."
So they're getting attention from you.
So that's a bit of a joke though, isn't
it? Like
he [laughter] clarified.
Look at the bigger picture. Look at the
bigger picture. That's what I'm saying.
He's making time. I let it go.
But you're making but you're making time
for his wives, which is the most
important thing. So they're not like
[laughter]
imagine if you don't turn up and then
you're setting her up FOR
complicated as men. Like you don't even
need to go out for for me. If you turn
up at home and you've had a long day and
you, you know, you don't really want to
go out, but you want to do something
with your wife, I would say invest in a
white um cloth for a table and buy a
candle, set it up, switch the lights
off.
Still spontaneous. That's still
spontaneous. That's still spontaneous.
That's what I'm talking about. He's
saying don't be predictable. And that's
very important. Like sisters like drama.
They like watching drama. Yeah. Yes.
Yes. Yes. Yes. Let's be real here. Do
you know Do you know why I'm saying
stuff like this? Because I genuinely
believe I'm kind of look I'm kind of on
the manh of mai on this sense. Why?
Because I don't agree with everything he
says and he knows that. Yeah. People
have a go at me. Why do you invite him?
I don't care about people's opinions.
Okay. There are certain things I believe
he says. There are certain things I've
called him up on. There are certain
things he disagrees with me. But the
point of the show is to come and talk to
people I disagree and and agree with.
But there are certain truths which he
says which is important to understand
the inner dynamics and hardwiring of
women. It's for our brothers, not for
you guys. is for the men to understand
being unpredictable. Women like it not
to the level where I'm coming in 30
minutes, we might go out. I know which
show you didn't mean. It's that in 30
minutes be ready. We're going out. It's
it's random. It's spontaneous.
Mean it, but I'll provide the rest of
the the answer.
Okay, go on. Thank you. That's what I'm
talking about. Give me if we don't go
out, we're going to do something at home
anyway. That was the end of that line.
But that was only that was only because
there was some other things going on
irrespective. But when I I don't
actually ask my women what they want to
do. I just tell them,
babe, this is what we're doing. Get your
stuff. Isn't it?
Absolutely. Yeah. They love it. And and
the beautiful thing about this behavior
is that I take all decision making away
from them.
And that's good. Okay. That's that's
right.
What about the house?
Like what about the house?
Do that.
She has things in the house. So if she
says, you know what, look, I want this
furniture. I want this to be like this.
Like are you
I don't care about the house. So the
house is looking like
can I just say um I think it's getting a
bit detailed now. So, you're talking
about your women because you know your
women, you've studied them and you
understand your women.
I was Did you want to say something on
the topic before she switched up the
gear? Switch gears.
Was there something you wanted wanted to
say?
But let's let's stick to the top. We got
15. Look, we got 15 minutes.
So, I was going into love language and
understanding your spouse. It goes both
ways. So, if I know my man, I know
that's what he'd like. And you know your
women and you know what they like. So,
as far as
No, I don't care. I don't care. I don't
care. I don't care what women like. I
care what they respond to.
But your type of women, did you catch
that ball? I don't care what women want.
I care what they respond to.
Absolutely fine. And I agree with you.
That's your wives.
No, no, no. There's a common theme of
whoever
marries you has to respond to you like
that. Matthew, correct?
I have a question.
Yeah. But if she wants, but let's say
you hit her up and you say, "This is
what we're doing. Get ready." And then
she says, "Hang on a minute. But I want
to do something different." Like, how do
you respond to that?
They never do.
They never do. Listen. No, because
there's two brothers sitting next to
you. I don't know if you're married.
Yeah, we're married.
You want to deal with your wife the same
way he does with this? This is it. The
thing is this is what everyone want uh
are different with their wife. That's
me.
That's me's way.
My thing is this. How do you know all
women want that?
Yeah. Your experience when you got Let
me finish. Let me finish. Let me finish.
Cuz your experience is limited to the
women that you've been for been with and
they're from a certain background. Okay.
If you've been with a woman from every
single country, married to all of them
four at a time, you know,
all the trauma and different
then you can make a generalized comment
like that.
That's a really good question and it
requires a response. So outside of
obviously my own anecdotal experience
which doesn't stretch very far. Okay. If
you want to talk about the hundreds of
clients that I've consulted myself
because that's what I do my private
time. They pay me £1,000 an hour for
that. If you want to talk about an hour,
£1,000 an hour
and it's going to go up because the cost
of time is is you you understand how to
calculate cost.
Yeah.
Throwing that.
And there are common there are
behavioral traits that women can't help
but gravitate towards when you display
them despite it annoying them.
And and and my clients that I've
consulted, okay? And you you will find
that there is an inverse relationship.
You can only press it once as you can
see between what makes her happy
and what keeps her engaged. And I am
less interested in what makes her happy
and more interested in what keeps her
engaged.
You do both.
Yeah.
Because keeping her engaged does both.
Keeping her happy. But you just
differentiated. You said that keeping
her um engaged does both. And then you
said keeping her Keeping her engaged
will definitely keep her type of
engagement. She might be annoyed,
but keeping her happy exclusively better
than hugby chasing her happiness
[laughter] exclusively.
What's the fastest what's the fastest
way to make a woman about exclusivity of
the two two? We're not saying that
they're mutually exclusive. I said, why
can you not do both? I've got I've got
something else to say
by doing this.
By doing what? If you focus on what
keeps her engaged, she might dislike
elements of it, but ultimately she'll
love you, respect you, and her overall
happiness will be greater if you chase
her happiness exclusively.
No, no, no. I'm not saying they're
mutually exclusive. Can I just go back?
You just differentiated between
engagement and happiness. And then when
I asked you about it, you said that
engagement um ticks the box of
happiness, but then you differentiated
happiness. So, they're not the same.
I heard you, but you didn't hear me.
No, I heard you.
I heard you, but you didn't hear No, no,
you've not heard me cuz I'm asking you
that you've you've differentiated
between happiness and engagement.
So just because a woman is happy doesn't
mean that she is
engaged. I have to keep this PG. Just
because she's happy with you doesn't
mean she's engaged. Fine. Okay.
But when she is engaged, she might be
annoyed with you, but her overall
happiness with you and satisfaction will
be greater.
I don't agree.
The fastest way to make a woman
miserable, guess what? Give her
everything she wants. Ali just pointed
it out just now. That's the fastest way
to make
it's it's true.
Now, so just just can we do with amongst
prophecy? Okay.
Yeah. Yeah.
Now, what like I said to you before,
look, I agree with a lot of stuff
Matthew says. There's a lot of stuff I
disagree with which I've been vocal
about to previous shows as well. What
Matthew does is which I believe there's
a lot of things that he puts which I
believe he has experience. Yeah. Um but
what you do is sometimes Matthew is you
take it step it up a notch. That step up
notch works I think with your wives. So
what you say generally there's a lot of
stuff foundation I agree with. Bang bang
bang. I'm like good good. the stuff that
you say where you're like like I decide
everything. I'm like okay that maybe
works with your wife. Like for example
me and like my wife for example when I'm
like okay uh for example there were a
couple of instances in our house where I
ordered specific things. Um usually it's
the house it's her kingdom but sometimes
she'd be like no no no give me a chance
I will refund it. I promise you let's
buy it and she know she's here maybe
four or five instances where I've bought
it and she's like actually that was a
good idea. That was like that was
actually a good idea. So sometimes yes
you're right. But in certain instances,
do I speak to my wife? Like, am I just a
ruler over her? Of course not. There's
sometimes where she would say an idea
where I'm like, actually, that's
interesting. So, it's important
sometimes what you're saying works with
your wife and there's nothing wrong.
Nobody can have a go inequality thing,
marriage dynamics. It's catered for
them. As long as it's halal, nobody can
say it's wrong. Brilliantly works. I
always
so yeah just to clarify what meth said
for example look again I'm not saying
this to like it's nothing to be praised
with something to be ashamed of but I
come from a jah 10 years of jah 10 years
of Islam so in a nutshell there's
certain things he says it's true I'm so
sorry I don't care if anybody hates it
if he didn't speak in certain aspects
what I'm saying but when it comes to
like being spontaneous etc being a
leader most of the times directing and
leading I'm so sorry it works and even
sisters will testify to that however I
believe sometimes meth steps up a notch
which I believe it works with his
household dynamics which as long as it's
halal it is permissible in that instance
and we know from the sunnah proam that
most of the times it's the woman that
have to please the husband but what do I
mean by that you you never see it vice
versa in the in the Quran or the sunnah
this doesn't mean we neglect and we
don't what we're seeing is a man has
responsibility which he does he needs to
be protect and providing when it comes
to dean emotionally taking care of etc
but if if I'm telling this outright if a
man was to chase in the sense where his
objective was how can I make my wife
happy I'm so sorry you would never make
her happy I'm so sorry the dynamics are
this is the dynamics this doesn't mean
you don't want to make her happy it's if
you tried to make her in totality if you
said to her what would make you happy
and I'll give one evidence in the sense
which is what why does Allah subhanaa
tala not mention in the Quran what you
guys are going to get in Jenna there's
general specific things rivers of honey
rivers of water why doesn't Allah go
into specific
because every single woman is different
in very much not only that and every
woman in our hard wiring is also the
same. We as men we are told very
clearly. Yes. Look horain and um a few
other things in the Quran. It directly
tells us what we want and we all get
gassed and happy about it. But if Allah
said to you guys, you're going to get a
palace with five bedrooms.
You're going to be thinking and and if
Allah said it's going to be pink color.
Yeah. You're going to be thinking but I
want it blue color and I want seven
bedrooms. It's Allah has left that to
your imagination cuz your imagination
which is unique to you guys. It's
nothing. It's not blamew worthy. It's
unique. You your imagination is wild and
you want this and that. That's fine. But
we're seeing if we go to the pursuit of
what does my wife want to make her
happy, we are doomed and finished.
But that's do you understand? That's the
thing.
Perhaps maybe there's also the
perspective that perhaps Allah hasn't
actually told uh us as women what we're
going to get cuz it's better than what
you're going to get. So
you might feel like in you know it's not
good enough.
I've got I've got something really
important to say.
One thing I want to touch up one thing I
want to touch up on is this though. The
moment I mentioned that why did it come
across as something you want is inferior
what you want is more with us is very
simple lane I can go to the markets fly
around in Jenna a bit come back to my
lane okay so the thing is with you guys
with sisters no I'm saying the fact that
Allah has left that you can say I want
this and I want that I'm I'm not saying
it inferior com I'm saying we are look
would you agree we are men we are direct
and sisters are indirect
okay would you agree that you guys have
hormones that make instability sometimes
that's sometimes all the time that's why
I Thank you. I appreciate Allah bless
you timing.
Thank you. So sister, what we're saying
is this because of those factors of hard
wiring from your side and our side.
We're seeing this works. That's why I I
agree with what he said. We deal with
what works.
Yeah. So I just want to make that
disclaimer with and his wife that works
for them. Happy for them and may Allah
bless and preserve them. Nobody can say
nothing as long as it's halal. But my
dynamics with my wife would be totally
different. what 80% 85% of the things
that he's saying it's I would say there
there is men that they should implement
that
I agree with you by the way I don't
disagree with you okay with with with
regards to what you were just saying
about your the way you deal with your
wives okay I don't I don't disagree
but there's a key thing that you didn't
mention which I feel like I want to
highlight is it's the timing okay you're
not like that all the time with your
wives you're not speaking to them like
that in that manner all the time and for
women it's the timing and this is why I
say if you understand us then you
understand okay sometimes a day she's
not in the mood sometimes the day she's
in the mood we're very up and down you
know like we don't want attention all
the time it does it irritates us it
drives us mad it's annoying actually we
do want space let me um just say
something about like with brother Mahi
I've known him for time I love him as a
Muslim brother I do love him as a Muslim
brother but I don't agree with some of
the things and and the thing is what I
say whatever it is his home situation
that's his home situation wherever ever
he does in his house, that's his own
house. And that's how he runs his house.
And he's happy. His wife's happy. He's
happy. But with my thing is if you keep
your wife happy and show the love, she
will never ever cheat on you.
She will never ever cheat on you. But
every
I keep them happy.
Yeah, that's that's what I mean.
You said you keep them engaged.
Happy said their happiness doesn't
matter.
Why does No, he they're engaged in
happiness. They are engaged and that
that keeps them happy. But chasing her
happiness, it's like me sitting here.
Ladies, what would make you happy? I
couldn't care less. I what I care is
what keeps them engaged because long
term that is what's going to keep her
happy. If I chase, hold on, let me land.
If I chase her happiness exclusively,
like a tick list. Okay. So, she said
this.
That's fine.
That's clear. Right. Then this is a road
to destruction.
No, I did it. No, it's true. He cares
about his wife's happiness.
If women, it's true.
If we if the guy comes to us and he's
like he's totally tailored and he's
perfect to our emotion at that moment.
This why I said it comes back to timing
with us women. Okay. Sometimes
but the timings change
you got to study your wife.
Did you not say okay arguments your
husband comes to you and says what would
you like make you happy? You would say I
want your attention. But do you remember
just before that you said but not all
the time.
Yes. That's why
do you see why we say we cannot. The
reason why is because the moment I give
you your attention like wrong timing. Do
you see what we mean? That is where we
are coming from.
But every relationship
understand
you got to understand your wife like
even when the time of the month comes
and that and your wife is totally
different and you pick up on that
and the thing is you deal with it in a
different way. You take because the way
she is. So all of these things that you
have to understand your wife and if you
don't understand her then
exactly when they're about to come on
their menstrual cycle this is very
important some women suffer from PMS
okay
sorry what's that
uh uh post yeah premenal depression as
well they get depressed they get anxious
depress after the period
no before so you'll find that the
woman's very agitated she doesn't want
you nowhere near her sex drive goes down
she's like just get out my face why are
you in the house go away she's crying
for no reason she's sitting in the
corner crying. We don't know why we're
crying.
Seriously, that's the point where we're
saying that's the reason why which I
agree with me though. He's saying if we
were to pursue that, look, before
menstrual cycle, you got about 7 days.
Before that, let's add 3 days. 3 days
after it, you're looking at 13 days.
That's near half a month.
No, but don't you get it? The time is
what you need to women. It's the timing.
Yes, you the way, however you patting up
the situation with your woman is
absolutely fine, but you need to know
that your woman and what type of woman
you're dealing with. The same for us
women. We need to know the type of man
we're dealing with to approach him if we
do have issues and we want to approach
him. If you got an aggressive man who's
a bit arrogant, is a bit of a knock,
then you don't just come and tell him
something in his face that he's probably
going to lash out. So there's a like you
said, there's a hikmma to do it.
Then mi then you we're going to wrap up
show. We got 5 minutes. Let's just quick
wrap up say um hopefully this episode
was a good episode and it helps everyone
stop doing haram or stop them cheating
or you know what I mean? So hope we all
help gave you some pointers.
What's your name again?
Hussein.
Hussein made an important distinction
just now where she asked me so you said
so you do want your wife to be happy
then? And and the answer to that is of
course I want my wife to live in like
some miserable life of depression. No
ultimately of course I want them to be
happy. I'm just saying the root to their
happiness is not what they tell us it
is. That's it.
Yeah.
Sorry. Can I just get you to Oh, sorry.
Sorry. I didn't see you there.
Um,
I want to know the root.
So, closing remarks. Why women cheat?
Um, I don't know.
It depends on the [clears throat] I I've
heard quite a lot of things to be
honest. Um, I I didn't understand quite
a few of the definitions, but what I
will say this as a man that's married,
I'll take the responsibility. I'll take
responsibility. I'll say just be nice to
your wife. Be kind to her. Respect her.
Provide her what she needs. and just see
how it goes. And if it doesn't work out,
you know, divorce is an option.
My opinion,
y
would be understand her. Understanding
is key
because when you understand her, her
needs, then overall you'll be able to
just like allow her to be herself.
She'll be authentic, you know, and so
yeah, you could just do your thing as a
man, as a husband.
Thank you, sister.
Let's up from sister Laki dopamine and
wrap-up show. What are we doing?
Statements just in a nutshell. Advice to
men who are watching this when we
discuss topic,
right? Um um ultimately, so obviously
this topic of conversation is about why
women cheat. We've already discussed why
women cheat. But at the end of the day,
regardless of what situation you're in,
whether they whether you're being
emotionally neglected or not, this is
directed to the women. You are respon is
responsible in the eyes of Allah. You're
going to be held accountable
regardless of what situation you were
put in. Whether you were emotionally
neglected or your physical needs weren't
met, you are responsible for the act of
cheating and that's it. you are
responsible and you need to bear that in
mind that one day you're going to stand
before Allah
and you're going to have to explain to
Allah why you decided to cheat on your
husband
even even though you had other outlets
like divorce him communicate with him um
get other people involved whatever the
outlet is do not disobey Allah that's it
do not disobey Allah don't go against
Allah
it's very very fundamental So this is
very key in the May Allah bless you
because it shows accountability because
a lot of sisters hate it. They blame
Yeah.
sisters. Exactly. So may Allah bless
you.
Yeah. I just want to go more into the
Quran and advise people to read the
Quran cuz a lot of people we're not
reading it and
honestly if you read the Quran there's
so much gems in there and it's very
simple and I feel like Allah is very
very clear in the statements when it
concerns man and women how we should
treat each other. So yeah, I just want
to say that just read the Quran and
understand what Allah's asking of you
and how to treat your spouse and
inshallah you you will find a person
who's compatible for you and yeah, you
got your little thing going on.
That works.
Um so to kind of conclude on the
question why women cheat, women cheat
because um there's been a fundamental
there's been a fundamental neglect of
their feminine needs point. But that is
not an excuse to as a female to go out
and treat your husband in such a way. If
you feel that you have come to that
point where thoughts are crossing your
mind, where there's interaction that's
you know started where you've
disconnected actually because that's the
starting point. That's where it goes
downhill. You've disconnected from your
husband then you need to take
responsibility to action the solution.
Whether that is you seeking support of
external parties to help you navigate
and return to the marriage in the way
that you hoped it would be at the
beginning or you make a decision to um
seek whatever you define as your
happiness if you're not finding it in
that marriage and um deal with the
marriage in an integ integrous way.
whether you decide to stay in it or
leave it, you need to maintain your
integrity and that comes down to your
and the deen um and don't compromise
that um at the end of the at the end of
the day. Alhamdulillah, Islam has given
us solutions given us the right to tal
for reasons such as in lack of intimacy,
you know, which actually other religions
don't provide. Um Judaism, you're not
allowed to get divorced.
Yeah. Catholicism until very, you know,
in some countries still exist. That's
the reason Henry Henry the A was killing
his wives because he couldn't divorce
them. He was like, "Let me get rid of
them."
Yeah. You know, um we're in a country
and in countries where we we have those
options especially. So, you know, you
have rights. And what all I'm going to
conclude with is don't disrespect
someone else at the cost of your
happiness. It should just be seeking out
your happiness and being respectful.
Yes. Brothers and sisters, may Allah
bless our honorable guest. And no she
she no we started with her first.
Yeah we started with you first in it to
finish.
Yeah we did her first and then yeah she
was first. You guys were second third
for fourth. Yeah. Yeah. So um inshah
sisters. So guys in a nutshell I believe
this wholeheartedly. Alhamdulillah. And
you don't need to pay £1,000. Uh I'm
joking. So in a nutshell guys if you are
the man you are fearing Allah God
conscious high value man is not what the
red people says. You're a god-conscious
man who fears Allah who who cares about
of yourself and your partner. Um you are
a good man, a a man who is vocal
emotionally in different ways. Your wife
hears uh the love and feels the love.
Inshallah I believe brothers and sisters
your wife would never ever in their the
way they are created they are monogous
by nature. They would never ever look at
another man. So be the best version you
can be in the sight of Allah and make
sure Allah subhanaa tala comes first and
when you become that man alhamdulillah
don't worry about this and if it happens
that's between her and the lord and
she'll be accounted for that and the
next episode which we'll do inshallah
maybe next month is why men are disloyal
which will be a whole topic in itself
because this required a whole topic in
itself till next time brothers and
sisters from bitter truth may Allah
bless our honorable sisters and our
honorable brothers for coming here and
uh they're takingah if you want to apply
on the panel please uh on the link uh
there's a email the link below you can
do that asalam allayikum
Okay, sir.